Let's start by talking about what is a real-time PBR. So PBR is a unified
lighting shading system. It approximates light in real life behavior so you can
see these materials kind of reacting in the scene as you would expect that
type of material. Maybe it either reflects a lot of light or absorbs
light and doesn't have as much specularity. You can dial in these
values based on the material regardless of the type of texture that you're
using so we try to create something that's more physically accurate so it
uses real physical measurements such as lumens and looks and inverse square law
energy conservation etc and it's just a little bit more intuitive and consistent
to understand when you're creating your projects. It also produces just a
more accurate and natural look as you can see in these images here. When we
talk about material concepts with PBR we generally can divide the materials we
build into metals and non-metals so non-metals and metals on the right hand
side here you can see that we can create the desired approach based on a
type of material concept as seen in these images. So if we're thinking first
about base color which we call an albedo map so non-metals, color
info always have some kind of range there's no pure whites or pure blacks
in nature so we want to keep in mind a roughness is a key in defining the look
of a material as it's selling in the real world so you can see the
non-metals here we have some RGB values and sRGB values and we might be
approaching if we want a non-metal concept we might be approaching it
more like this whereas a metal concept again we'll be using just different
information to get our PBR material to react in a different way we have levels
of metallic that we can change based on zero to one so it's a grayscale value
ranging from zero to one and the most common usage is either one or
zero it is more binary in that respect so when on it results in a
hundred percent specular reflection as you can see on the right hand side of
the image here zero would be on the left hand side and you can see all the
values in between again it's most common to use either zero one kind of binary
approach however obviously the results will depend on what effects you
are actually going after we also have roughness masks which is again a
grayscale value ranging between zero and one but roughness materials will
scatter the reflected light in more directions than a smooth material might
so if you want a more mirrored surface that is on the zero end this time a bit
more reflective and then a more matted surface is going to be the one value
here so again you can dial it in from zero to one based on how rough
you want that material to feel and then we've got a few credits here the
broom was created by Fabrice Briely and we've got some additional
resources here on physically based index if you want to dig into those